Now in general and you might have come across one or more of these examples,
using randomness is of course quite important in Computer Science.
You might've come across randomness, for example, in crytography
where randomness is in a way the only way to fully securely encode a message.
You might've encountered randomness in something called symmetry breaking.
Let's say you walk down a hallway and somebody comes in your direction,
and you're trying to get out of the way of that person but the moment that you get out of the way,
that person also tries to get out of the way in the same direction,
and so if you did not have random decisions, then you would almost certainly crash into each other.
And finally randomness is often used in simulations,
so when you do physics simulation or financial scenarios,
then of course, also randomness is something very, very useful.
Now, the difficulty with using randomness to solve NP complete problems is this,
in all of these examples here, being as random as possible is something rather desirable.
So in cryptography, you want perfect randomness because that gives you the most security.
Symmetry breaking works best if you have as much randomness as possible,
so that these two entities, say, will make completely independent decisions of each other.
And in simulation of course too, because the point of using randomness
in simulation is to simulate random processes, so you want to model that as good as possible.
Now for NP complete problems, this doesn't work because for NP complete problems,
we don't want perfect randomness.
What we are looking for is a needle in a haystack and finding a needle in a haystack
simply by poking it from a few random directions won't really help.
And that is why we need to direct our randomness.
Let's say, you use randomness in a very naive way to solve clique
and just assign all of the vertices, random values of 0 and 1.
Now let's say you're doing this for a graph with n vertices.
Well, actually I think you can answer this question if I give you four choices from which to choose.
So is it 1/n²? Is it (1/2)^n? Is it 1/2  n? or is it 2^n/n²?